[Music]
guys
wow i have a story yeah cool i like
story about
this 39 year old man keep going the
whole [ __ ] video
who has 32 degrees and certifications
under his oh this
what a loser this fall oh my god this
guy's
i seen this guy he looks like he has 32
degrees okay
boy does he actually apply them though
or does he just uh
professionally just gradually just
habitually [ __ ] continues to study he
also looks like a virgin
big time he looks like he [ __ ] books oh
that's kind of hot
poor guy but i agree you probably he
probably just scared
to join the real life because he's like
no all i know is school
and like if he's out of school then like
i want to watch him [ __ ] he's
addicted to learning bro he's addicted
oh [ __ ] which degrees are they too
though
okay it's s-t-s-e-s-s-o-s-s-h-a-s it's a
different country
yeah it's in indonesia it's like
bachelors i think but like in different
departments or whatever you know people
that go like oh i speak spanish and
venezuelan and argentinian and cuban
well i'm like that's the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know what i mean i
don't even i don't know what you mean
but i love it
that's so funny i want to laugh because
they're all
spanish countries this is just like oh
yeah they are so it's like saying you
speak alabama florida
texas wyoming well kind of because
there's different words for different
things that each one has their own like
spin on space so you use that as a whole
language it's hilarious yeah
okay anyway so yeah this dude he has 11
bachelor degree degrees three master's
degrees and 18 professional
certifications this is what he looks
like jokes aside that's [ __ ] cool
but back to jokes but doesn't he look
like what i explained
no he looks like the stoner guy in a
teen movie
that like he's he's like smoking a bong
he gets abducted by aliens
yeah oh that's a good movie i'm not in
this costume
no he looks he looks like [ __ ] i study
like put his hair longer
like if you had shoulder length yeah or
something and i mean that's the photo
that i saw
this one he's like i [ __ ] all these
books he does not look 39.
he spent every year in the library he
didn't age
i know that's crazy so by the time he
turned 18
in back in 1999 is when he received his
first
degree he looks like every asian kid in
the engineering department
how does he make money how does he pay
shouldn't he be the president if he
knows everything
so his first degree was an industrial
engineering
see every eight years into the
engineering department some hardships
that's hard [ __ ] okay it's tight what
else and so
i hope he's like it was easy i wish he
was here he's like that was easy
and then we're all like okay we feel
[ __ ] about ourselves cool
i think that knowledge without being
applied knowledge you it doesn't even
matter
like it you'll you'll forget like if i
learn how to
be an electrician but i never actually
did electricity
then like and i keep moving on to
different subjects i don't ever
i don't remember how to install a
chandelier i was a certified
phlebotomist i don't [ __ ] remember
anything i learned that dude
i remember the action of it but every
color tube
they have different enzymes that break
down the blood differently so it depends
on the type of
screening test like a lipids test or
whatever i would trust you you just
sound like you know
you just sound like you remember
everything remember like application and
repetition is the only way you like
actually
become knowledgeable and good at
something so when you do learn something
until you apply it you really
learn even more well some of these guys
they stay in school
as um like after you get a degree you
become a researcher and that's your
career
so you stay in the university as a
researcher and you're applying
your theory through that and then what
typically happens is like
they'll become a professor or whatever
but they'll stay in the lab
but in this case i don't even know if
like if it's one engineering degree and
one is like spanish no he just stays in
a classroom like
as a student forever forever but to get
those phds you have
you have to do research how does he make
money wait does he even have a phd no
right
it's just bachelors and masters yeah
yeah so they they are classrooms i want
to hear how he may
just judge him and not learn how he
makes money and assume that he doesn't
make any money
no because then you guys are all gonna
be like she didn't tell us what he's
done
i gotta tell you okay so i also okay
[ __ ] part go ahead i just also since
he has so many degrees i also want to
view him as like the pablo escobar of
school
so i feel like he just goes to people
with only one degrees like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
look at my thirty years yeah dude wait
till he has a kid dude that kid's gotta
get 40 degrees [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he knows
colombian too
does he it's just spanish you know the
whole plateau
in my head i just i i said like diploma
or diploma
no i was like the palm tree or diploma
i heard platinos like plantains mmm
urban i don't trust the stupid hair
section at all
excuse us we got antennas from god okay
so
you need to shut the [ __ ] up i'm tapping
into the matrix with my hair
you've been wanting to know nikki i'm
gonna answer this question so
his linkedin account lists him as a
pet store for one of indonesia's largest
company
a tax consultant and a business
consultant for a bank he also
founded he's so random his own tax
consulting company in april 2019 to
fulfill his dream of becoming an
integrated consultant
this guy must eat fast consulting is
another word for teaching and
those who don't do teach do you ever
heard of that line yeah yeah yeah sir
yeah well i just started from the
universe so
i like that he worked i like that he
works at a pet store i wish that
honestly all this build up was he works
at a pet store
that was fun she said and then and i
thought she was gonna say
animal i like that you said he eats fast
because i picture him with a bunch of
food he's a guy that has food in his
corn like the corner of his mouth still
oh yeah he's got no time like i crushed
cause he was like i just woke up and
he's got no [ __ ] time he smells like
bed you're working this much and
studying this much
yeah so he there was he's just super
smart and this is fun for him and we're
so average
people ask like how do you manage your
time to get all of these degrees and
certifications and he said that
uh once he took one degree course in the
morning
one at night and one on the weekends and
one exclusively on i thought you were
gonna say he got a degree in time
management
oh my god do you think his parents are
really proud of him because now he has a
bunch of degrees
go [ __ ] you if you have asian parents
you're never right so now
you have too many degrees why'd you have
so many degrees or it's like you don't
have enough
yeah it's like never ending no
they have a neighbor whose kid has more
degrees oh no
he's actually broken like records in
indonesia
for having this the heaviest book bag
that's true in indonesia though that's
the key you think that you know when you
write for a long time you get that bump
do kids even get that anymore oh [ __ ]
what if it's like [ __ ] really fat
yeah don't they do they get digital
bumps
i still have my butt
it's on the wrong finger though because
i write weird but i journal a lot it's
on this one
oh so it is because of writing i just
thought my fingers were crooked or
something
like i have something wrong with my
fingers i just have everyone looking at
me
neither oh i wasn't writing for that
long with a pencil
it reminds me of that kanye west like
you know the college dropout song where
he talks about
i got all these degrees i got a master's
i got a phd i got this
and it's like but you're broke is he
broke
this guy no but in the song i'm just
hoping he is so it fits that stereotype
oh okay we're all very insecure by this
well it says he's a consultant it
doesn't say like he's in a thriving
consulting business i can say i'm a
consultant and no one's hired me yet
i just hope that he's um not the
stereotype of a degree collector
because i think the stereotype that i
know of who is a you know
degree collectors they end up just kind
of staying there well he says that all
this knowledge
that he has gained over all these
degrees and
and certifications that they don't go to
waste because he uses
his knowledge in like day-to-day life
well he used him he used all those
degrees all that knowledge to earn one
[ __ ] medal like come on dude
he should be a decorated like you should
have so many [ __ ] medals you only
have one medal around
this one yeah look there's only one
medal i mean it's per graduation
yeah maybe he has 39 of these photos all
all the cap and gown
yeah [ __ ] yeah i do yeah i feel like
this full of slays [ __ ] though
he worth all the freaking is school
cheaper there
i don't know i don't know yeah i don't
know it might be like
what do you call it socializing because
here you have to be like a millionaire
to
like get that many degrees i feel like
in america yeah
like each each story is like yeah 200
000 true yeah that's a lot of money not
a dough man
well they're saying that he has no signs
of stopping anytime he wants more
degrees more degrees
yeah like he says like degrees and like
learning is what like keeps him going
i can relate with that though i relate
to that but we're the information age
you can literally learn anything you
want
anything you want and not that he wants
like he wants receipts like he wants to
like
show people exactly that's what i'm
saying he needs this the likes
but i also think that when you have a
mentor for
that department and they're guiding you
you learn way faster but i think the way
that school is structured it's too slow
yeah i would much rather have like a
total immersion yeah where you're in the
field but you also have a mentor
and you also have a lecturer and then
you're just spending eight hours on that
topic every single day
exactly i'd rather do that for like a
month straight than like
four years two weeks two days out of the
week you're going to class for an hour
too like that's what i'm saying he
should be more like gus learn a bunch of
different [ __ ] not that well
yeah i think we [ __ ] mastered that
[ __ ] the master of
disasters the jack of all trades yeah
like he should be an astronaut next i
mean if you're gonna be like this like i
think you should [ __ ] go for it have
you seen that guy he's like
he got into an ivy league he's a
astronaut he was a
navy seal we did a jk yeah and i'm all
like
if there's all these top level peoples
right i want to know who they are and i
want to pick their brain and i just want
to see how differently we
think because it's i i think i know a
lot of
you know successful people in their own
way and whatever but then
it's they're relatable like i want to
meet like a guy that's like wait you did
all this [ __ ]
how who are you i've never also met
someone that's three successful people
in one
yeah like it's already hard enough to do
one like it's it's hard to be an
astronaut navy seal he's a doctor too
he's a doctor astronaut yeah
look at that elon musk he did that
paypal
he did that tesla he's doing [ __ ]
spacex but that's all business
it's one thing yeah exactly he hires
people to do the things
but but also even to talk to him and
meet him
we don't have access to him so like just
sitting there with
mr elon or mr zuckerberg or anybody
for me like we can only kind of imagine
or listen to podcasts or interviews
right
but having that friendship that's crazy
that's some next level [ __ ] you can have
a friendship because you're so [ __ ]
busy all the time
true or just a couple of hours to seeing
them
in the flesh my my friends i i'm
actually one one degree away from
zuckerberg
my friend went to uh high school or
college with them and yeah okay is it
weird
give me the give me the scoop i know let
me ask you still keeps in touch
yeah yeah so so uh the way i found out
was
um my friend was uh producing some type
of
show that he was in and acting in and
then he was like [ __ ] no one would host
it and then
zuckerberg was like oh we'll just we're
doing uh [ __ ]
facebook tv and then we'll put you on
the front page
and then he got him on and that was that
that's cool let me ask you this though
if you could ask mark zuckerberg one
question because you want to talk to all
these like smart people
if you could ask mark zuckerberg one
question what was you asking how big is
your dick
what a waste of time what this would be
i knew it would be something like that
no see
but that's an important question oh dude
i would be like yo why'd you buy that
property around you like what do you got
to hide dude
yeah that's the [ __ ] i'm gonna go small
small dick small dude because that's
what motivated him see that's why it's a
good question
that's a good question the documentary
uh social what was it
you know what i would ask is because
every successful person warren buffett
everybody
if i ask them and they're like yeah i
got a small dick right then that tells
me yeah the key to success
is a small buffet warren buffett has a
big dick
really wait does he how do you know
i know uh and now you're destined for
success yes there we go
ah [ __ ] you guys
[Music]
you